[موسيقى]
انها ثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه هذه اخبار الساعه
اقرا لافته احتجاج في وجه طالبان بعد قمع
المراه
ومقترحا بتجميد المساعدات للضغط على
الحركه
المشانق تلاحق مئه متظاهر في ايران
ومحتجون يتحدون قمع النظام بالانتحار
والشطرنج
الثلوج تغمرون مناطق فيها الى ساحه حرب
شلل في بافلو جثث في سيارات ومحطات غاز
المجمده
2022 يسجل رقم القياسيا في اللجوء اكثر من
100 مليون لاجئ حول العالم اغلبهم فرونا
من اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
وسيتم اوقاتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
قبل ان نبدا من قصه الفتاه الافغانيه مروه
نبدا اذا باخر ردود الفعل الدوليه على
قيود طالبان الاخيره ضد المراه حيث اعرب
مجلس الامن عن قلقه من قرارات طالبان
معتبران ان تقييد عمل النساء يخالف
التزامات طالبان تجاهها حقوق الشعب
الافغاني سنتابع المزيد فيما يتعلق بهذه
المواقف بعد قليل اذا عوده الى قصه الفتاه
ضد طالبان اقرا بهذه اللافته احتجت الفتاه
الافرانيه مروه امام جامعتكابل على منع
الفتيات من التعليم مروه وقفت وحدها في
وجه طالبان ووجهها رساله لكل العالم حول
حجم الظلم والاضطهاد الذي تتعرض له للمراه
هناك رساله حملتان افغانيه في مناطق اخرى
حيث خرجت عده تظاهرات النسائيه اعتراضا
على قيود طالبان واصطاد دعوات لمزيد من
التحركات المدنيه للضغط على الحركه واخراج
المراه من عزلتها
[موسيقى]
بسنواتها 18 تقف مروه على قارعه الطريق في
كابول لكن في قلب الحدث
ترفع فوق راسها لوحه تحدي لقرار طالبان
القاضي باخراج الفتيات من الجامعات
والنساء العاملات من دائره الاقتصاد
وادخالهن دوامه الجهل والبطاله والفقر
بكلمه واحده تواجه ابنه جيل ما بعد طالبان
مقاتل الحركه الذين قفزوا الى السلطه بعد
عقدين من المبيت في الكهوف والجبال اقرا
تريد مروه من قيادات الطالبان ان تقرا في
صفحه مستقبل افغانستان لا ماضيها
بالنسبه لها ما هو اهم من المصالحه
الوطنيه التي اخرجت الرئيس الافغاني فارا
من البلاد واخضعت مقاتلي وادي بشير
الاسطوري
المصالحه مع المجتمع الافغاني نصفه تحديدا
لا شله وتعطيله
ان فتاه واحده وقفت ضد طالبان فان ذلك
سيساعدهن على النهوض وهزيمه طالبان
تقف مروه على هذا الطريق وحدها لكن ليست
وحيده
خلفها تيار كبير يرفض مشهد السلاح طالبان
على حقوق المراه
مشهد يؤكد ان المراه والفتاه الافغانيه لا
تقلان فيه شجاعه عن الرجل الافغاني
كلها لم تجد او لم تجدي نفعا في الضغط على
طالبان للتراجع على قراراتها الاخيره ضد
نسائها في افغانستان الحركه مصممه على عزل
المراه بكل الاشكال وتهدد بالمزيد لهذا
بدات اطراف دوليه ومنظمات الحقوقيه في
البحث عن سبل اخرى على طريقك وزيره
التنميه الالمانيه خرجت بمقترح ربما ينجح
وهو تجميد تقديم المساعدات لافغانستان حيث
اشارت الى انها تعتزم بالتعاون مع البنك
الدولي الدعوه الاجتماعي الاطراف الفاعله
في الصندوق صندوق اعاده اعمارستان وترحل
فكره
وبموازته ذلك انضمت للمزيد من المنظمات
الاغاثيه الاجنبيه التي علقت عملها في
افغانستان بعد قرار طالبان منعها من توظيف
النساء وفي بيان المشترك لعدد من تلك
المنظمات طالبات الرجال والنساء بمواصله
العمل على تقديم المساعدات لانقاذ الارواح
في افغانستان وعدم التوقف عن العمل وتحذر
المنظمات والامم المتحده من تعطل الاعمال
الانسانيه في افغانستان
وتاثرها بقرار طالبه
وفي ردود الفعل الدوليه اذا همم رد فعليا
اخر قبل قليل اعرب مجلس الامن عن قلقه
الشديد من قرار طالبان على الافغانيه من
التعليم الجامعي واضاف ان منع عمل النساء
في المنظمات يحمل وتدعيات على عمليات
الاراثه من جانبها ادانت مفاوضيه حقوق
الانسان في الامم المتحده القيود على حقوق
المراه في افغانستان واشارت الى ان هذه
القيود لا يمكن استيعابها وستزيد معاناه
وستشكل خطرا يتعدى حدود افغانستان
[موسيقى]
معنى من العاصمه الافغانيه كابو الحمزه
حكيمي وهو احد العاملين بالمنظمات
الاغاثيه الدوليه في افغانستان سعيد حمزه
اهلا بك معنا في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
ابدا معك من اخر التطورات على المستوى
الدولي مجلس الامن الدولي ندد الذي تفرضه
طالبان على النساء في افغانستان ودعها
للتراجع عن قراراتها هل برايك هذه المواقف
الدوليه يمكن ان تغير موقف الحكومه
الافغانيه
تحياتي لكم الاستاذ المشاهدين الكرام على
ما اعتقد ان هذه القرارات اذا فصلت وترجمت
بعقوبات سياسيه تضرب الكيان السياسي
لحكومه الطالبان ربما ستؤثر هذه القرارات
على هذا القرار لكن اذا ترجمت هذه
القرارات بالعقوبات الاقتصاديه ونقص او
منع المساعدات فهذا على ما اعتقد سيضرش
على الافغاني الشعب الفقير اكثر من
الحكومه لان هذه المساعدات لا تقدم الى
الحكومه بل تقدم الى الناس الفقراء وشعب
الافغاني الفقير فاذا منع هذه المساعدات
من افغانستان سيمنع المساعدات من الشعب
الافغاني من القاطع
ماذا تقصد عندما تترجم بطريقه سياسيه
اجراءات دوليه سياسيه ماذا تقصد
بالاجراءات السياسيه هنا
ربما ربما منع السفر عدم التعامل الرسمي
بقى الحكومه
تجميد الاصول الشخصيه لبعض القيادات
الموجوده في دول الاخرى ااا ممم قضيه ال
ال انعزال السياسي اكثر ربما ما هي يعني
بما ان الحكومه هي منعزل اصلا لكن بعض
الدول تتعامل معها كجها رسميه همم كل هذه
العقوبات السياسيه يمكن ان يؤثر على
الحكومه ككيان تحكم همم هذا البلد ان تكون
العقوبات موجهه ضد الحكومه الافغانيه وليس
ضد الشعب الافغاني بالعوده الى الى
المنظمات الدوليه المنظمات غير الحكوميه
كيف اثر قرار همم طالبا بمنع عمل النساء
كيف اثر على عمل همم هذه المنظمات سيد
حمزه
التاثير على ثلاث اصعده الصعيد الاول ان
هناك عدد كبير من الكفاءات من النساء كانت
تعمل داخل هذه المؤسسات المؤسسات التي انا
تعاملت معها واعمل معها وهناك كفاءات
عاليه من النساء الافغان طبال 20 سنه
الماضيه هذه الكفاءات قد بنيت والشعب
الافغاني يستفيد من هذه الكفاءات ستحرم
الم- المنظمات غير الحكوميه من هذه
الكفاءات على الدرجه الاولى الدرجه
الثانيه انه الاف من العوائل والاسر
الافغاني همم يعني دخلهم الوحيد همم ما
ياخذه وما تاخذه هذه النساء العاملات من
هذه المؤسسات والمنظمات غير الحكوميه
كرواتب هذه العوائل ستفقد همم هذا المصدر
والاثر الثالث هو ايصال الخدمات
للناس للفعل المستهدفه او الفئه المطلوبه
من ايصال الخدمات من همم النساء والفتيات
ف خدمات صحيه وهناك خدمات تنويه وخدمات
اخرى تقدم للنساء همم من جانب هذه
المنظمات التي تقدمها العاملين بهذه
المحيطه
لا يستطيع ان يقدم هذا الخدمات هذه
المنظمات بالمقابل علقت اعمالها في
افغانستان همم يعني كيف يؤثر هذا التعليق
عمل هذه المنظمات غير الحكوميه كذلك على
همم الاعانات التي كانت تقدم الافغان
هناك همم يعني همم مختلف القطاعات التي
تقدم الخدمات فيها هذه المنظمات فقط قطاع
الصحه قطع
قطعات التنميه البشريه وغيرها من من
المجالات في الحياه تقدم الخدمات كانت
تقدم من قبل هذه المواسات هناك ولايات
كثيره داخل الافغانستان التي فقد هذه
المنظمات هي التي تقدم هذه الخدمات فاذا
توقف هذه المنظمات توقف عملها تعلق
اعمالها هذا سيؤثر بشكل مباشر على القطاع
الصحه قطاع التنميه البشريه على قطاع همم
اعاده التاهيل المعاقين همم المنظمات
المساعدات الانسانيه العاجله وغيرها من
المساعدات ستؤثر بشكل مباشر على الفئه
الاكثر فقرا والاكثر ضرارا في افغانستان
والاضعف الفقراء الذين يسكنون في القرى
والمناطق المائيه في افغانستان
للمنظمات الاغاثيه الدوليه في افغانستان
شكرا جزيلا لك وانت معنا من كابول
[موسيقى]
كره كرتون
كره الارض
[موسيقى]
كامل حرب الاوكرانيه لكن الشروطه تبددها
اهلا بكم من جديد تطوير ايران صفحه 2022
على الانتفاضه مارس فيها النظام وكل اشكال
القمع ضد المتظاهرين من قتل وتعذيب
واعتقال وحتى اعدام منظمه حقوق الانسان
الايرانيه اعلن ارتفاع عدد قتلى المظاهرات
المستمره في البلاد منذ اكثر من ثلاثه
اشهر الى
476 قتيلا من بينهم اطفال
يواجهون حاليا خطرا الاعدام او اتهامات
تفضي الى هذه العقوبه
يوميا توثقوا في ايران مشاهد القمع والقتل
في اخرها تداول ناشطون فيديو صرخات ابنه
احد ضحايا الاحتجاجات كمال احمد بور في
مراسم مرور 40 يوما على وفاته كمال اصيب
بجروح خطيره على ايدي قوات الامن
الايرانيه وتوفي في طريقه الى المستشفى في
الثامنه عشر من نوفمبر المعطي
النظام الايرانيين في المقابل رفع سقف
التهديد ضد المتظاهرين متوعيدان
ابراهيم الرئيسي مؤكدا ان بلاده لن ترحم
ما وصفهم بالمعابين لايران تصريحات جاءت
امام دموع غفيره وسط ظهران خلال مراسمي
تشيع رفات الجنود قضوا خلال الحرب
الايرانيه العراقيه واشدد رئيسي على ان
حضن الامه الايرانيه مفتوح لكل من تم
التغرير بهم على حد الوصفه واتاها من رئيس
الايراني وسائل الاعلام بالتورط في
الاحتجاجات والترويجي لمعلومات المغلوطه
فيما هدد مؤسسات الاعلاميه ناطقه
بالفارسيه في الخارج
وفي ظل الاجراءات القمعيه التي تتخذها
السلطات الايرانيه ضد المتظاهرين اظهرنا
الرياضيات ايرانيات تضامنهن مع خلع الحجاب
في محافل وطنيه واخرى عالميه
[موسيقى]
والى موضوع الحرب الاوكرانيه الان الحلو
الدبلوماسي مره اخرى يحوم حول الحرب في
اوكرانيا هذه المره الكلام اتم من
اوكرانيا وليس من موسكو التي كانت المحت
من جهتها على لسان مسؤليها الى استعدادها
للتفاوض وزير الخارج
بتصريح في بصريح العباره الى ان الحاله
الديبلوماسيه هو المخرج الحتمي للحرب لكن
وفقا المكاسب المحققه على الميته
كله حربي تنتهي بطريقه دبلوماسيه ونتيجه
التطورات التي تتم في ساحه المعركه وعلى
طاوله المفاوضات وهي مرتبطه ايضا بما يتم
كسبه في ساحه المعركه وما يتم كسبه ايضا
في المفاوضات
تصريح مع اعلان اوكرانيا عزمها عقد قمه
السلام بحلول الذكرى الاولى لبدء لعمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في شهر فبراير القادم
وذلك بواسطه من الامم المتحده وامينها
العام انطونيو جوترش غير ان روسيا ليست
مدعوه في هذه القمه الا اذا واجه الجرائم
حرب امام محكمه دوليه حسب تاكيدات وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني هذا وابدا الامين
العام للامم المتحده استعداده للتوسط في
الازمه في اوكرانيا فقط بموافقه جميع
الاطراف بما في ذلك روسيا
موسكو وان المحت مرارا عن استعدادها
للتفاوض الا ان العقبه الاساسيه تبقى شروط
التي يضعها كل طرف فردنا على رغبه
اوكرانيا في عقلي قمه السلام قال المتحدث
باسم الكربلاند متر سكوب انه لا امكانيه
لاجراء مفاوضات سلام مع كلاب شروطها مضيفا
ان روسيا لم تتبع ابدا شروط الاخرين بل
تلتزم فقط باهدافها الخاصه المنطقيه
معنا عبر سكايب من كيف بلودو مير
شوماكوماسيه السابق سيد فلودومير فرصه
نجاح اي تفاوض بين روسيا واوكرانيا اذا
كان كلى الطرفين يضع شروط مسبقا ويتمسك
بشروط
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]
هو اللي تعويضات ولكن نعم اعد ذلك سيد
البلوبير يعني اوكرانيا تتمسك بان ينسحب
الروس من كل الاراضي التي سيطروا عليها
هذا هذا منطقي ولكن في المقابل روسيا كذلك
يعني همم
استثمرت كثيرا في هذه الحرب لتحقيق
اهدافها وهي كما كانت تقول ابعاد قوه حلف
شمال الاطلسي هو والاسلحه من على حدودها
وبالتالي وهناك من يرى انه روسيا هي تبحث
عن مصر في هذه الحرب فكيف يمكن لها ان
تقبل الانسحاب وهي تتقدم على الارض يعني
هي لم تخسر الحرب كيف تجبر على انسحاب من
اراضي سيطره عليها
نكون صريحين روسيا لما تحقق اي شيء
اهدافها خلال هذه الفتره طويله بالعكس
تقريبا
هذه الحرب يجب ان تنتهي اي حرب هي في
نهايه ستنتهي بالمفاوضات بين الطرفين
المتحاربين همم
والغالب هو الذي يضع شروطه في في النهايه
هل تعتقد ان اوكرانيا عبر الدعم الغربي
بما فيه الدعم الغربي قادره على تحرير كل
المناطق التي سيطر عليها الروس
ان سوف تكون المفاوضات ولكن على شروط
اوكرانيه
يعني شروط روسيه هي كمان معروفه هذا
اعتراف
المختلطه بانها روسيه
للاتحاد اوروبي وبهذا اصابنا نحن نطرح
لماذا نحن نحاربون مع روسي لان شروط غير
مقبوله لاكرانيا بصفتها اكيد همم يكون كل
حرب تنتهي بطريقه المفاوضات ولكن انا
اعتقد الان الان طرفين غير مستعيدين
للمفاوضات السلام هدفه يعني هذا تحرير
المناطق اوكرانيه في اقرب وقت شكرا جزيلا
شو مالك
حدثنا من كيف
وفي خطوه تصعيديه من قبل موسكو وقع الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين مرسوما يحضروا
توريد النفط والمنتجات النفطيه للدول التي
فرضت سقفا لاسعار الخام الروسيه على ان
يدخل القرار حيز تنفيذ في الاولي من
فبراير جو باطا 2023 ويستمر لمده خمسه
اشهر حتى الاول من يوليو تموز
[موسيقى]
طوران ودفاع الاقليميه التابعي للقوات
الاوكرانيه برج مراقبه بهدف مراقبه تحركات
القوات الروسيه البرج اعتمدها على مبدا
مشابه لاجهزه المراقبه الامريكيه ويحمل
كاميرا بمدى خمسه كيلومترات
[موسيقى]
كيف
كاميرا فيديو
[موسيقى]
والى اخباري العاصفه في امريكا تحولت
مدينه بافلو في نيويورك الى اشبه ما يكون
ساحه حرب حرب مع الطبيعه هذه المره مع ذلك
الابيض الذي اتى بكل قسوته وشراسته هذا
العام هكذا وصفت حاكمه ولايه نيويورك
الوضع في المدينه المنكوبه عشرات الضحايا
بعضهم جرف مع الثلوج واخرنا حوصروا واعاقه
الثلوج وصول طواقم الطوارئ لانقاذهم
سيارات طمرت تحت الثلوج منازل بلا كهرباء
وعائلات المحاصره حتى الحركه مجمده ولا
بوادر على الحصار عاصفه
[موسيقى]
الطقس القادسيه ادى الى انخفاض درجات
الحراره في 48 ولايه امريكيه الى مدينه
صفر فطلق تجمده كل شيء حتى حقول وخطوط
انابيب الغاز مع عطله عند ذات الغاز
الطبيعي في الولايات المتحده فانخفضت نسبه
انتاج الغاز الذي يستخدم في التدفئه
وتوليد الكهرباء 10% بسبب تجمد الكثير من
المحطات ماذا فعل شركات الكهرباء
المواطنين الى ترشيد استهلاك الطاقه لتجنب
انقطاعات الكهرباء طبعا خطوه صعبه في ظل
عاصفه ثلجيه بارده الى احد التجمد
تتوقف الان مشاهدينا مع هذه الصور
المباشره لدينا اذا صوره اذا من نيويورك
كما تتابعون صور اييه من مدينه
بافلو طبعا في ولايه نيورك وهي الاكثر
اثرا بهذه العاصفه التي وصفت بانها عاصفه
القرن
وبانها من احوال الطقس التي ربما قد
يشهدها المرء لمره واحده فقط في حياته اذا
نذهب من بافلو في نيويورك نذهب الى لوس
انجلوس اذن من المطار هناك مع استمرار همم
ارتباك حركه الطيران اذا همم وتعليق الاف
الرحلات الجويه بسبب هذه العاصفه العاصفه
الغد على مستوى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه نحو 20,000 رحله جويه ورفعت عدد
ضحايا لاكثر من خمسينه شخصا بالنسبه
لنيويورك حاكمتها شبهتها الوضع بعد
العاصمه بانها ساحه حرب مع انخفاض درجات
الحراره كما ذكرنا حصر ركاب وبعض السكان
الفارين من منازلهم شديده البروده على
الطرق السريعه مع تعذر التدخل لانقاذهم
نتابع ظن الوضع عن كتب من نيويورك مع
الصحافي طارق الدمشقي طارق اهلا بك معنا
همم يعني الوضع في بافلو خصوصا في ولايه
نيويورك شديد الصعوبه المدينه مشلوله
لخمسه ايام حتى الان ماذا تقول التنبؤات
الجويه هل سيستمر هذا الوضع طويل
حقا هذه العاصفه التي وصفت بعاصفه القرن
لم تشهد منها مثلها البلاد هناك مقارنه
بينها وبين العاصفه التي ضربت منذ 43 عاما
انها يعني هذه العاصفه تفوقها في عدد
الضحايا ضحايا تلك العاصفه كان 30 الان
الذي احصي حتى الان حوالي 50 منهم 14 جثه
متجمده وجدت في ااا في السيارات العالقه
في الثلوج او ااه في الذين قطعت فيهم همم
الدروب همم محاوله الهروب من العاصفه ااه
حكي طارق لفتني يعني المشهد من خلفك انت
في نيويورك ولكن الجو لا يبدو مثلجا عندك
يعني هل همم ليست كل نيويورك متاثره
بالعاصفه
ولايه نيويورك ولايه كبيره جدا من حيث
المساحه دائما العواصف الثلجيه الكبيره
التي تضرب ولايه نيويورك تضرب الشمال
الغرب منها ولايه مدينه بوصلو على وجه
التحديد من الناحيه الجغرافيه هي اقرب الى
حدود كندا اقرب الى القطب الشمالي وهذه
المنطقه حتى في الصيف تعتبر بارده جدا
تبعد مدينه وصلوا عن الشلالات العظيمه
ياجاره حوالي خمس دقائق في السياره فقط
يعني ايضا اذا اردنا ان نعود قليلا سبع
سنين الى الوراء في عام 2015
همم مصاحبه للساقيه فقط ثلوج ولكن هذه
العاصفه حولت الثلج الى صقيع
والى جليد جليد جدا خطير حتى على يعني على
كل انواع السيارات همم اليوم همم حكيمه
الولايه ارسلت الشرطه العسكريه لضغط همم
الحركه المروريه هناك ومنع السيارات يعني
لفرد همم عدم التجول في السيارات في
المنطقه عموما في منطقه بوخالو والقرى
يعني ااا
طارق في ظل هذا الوضع والطقس السيء جدا
عاصفه القرن كما ااا سمتها حاكمه نيويورك
هناك انقطاع في الكهرباء هناك ازمه الطاقه
كذلك كيف يتدبر الامريكيون امورهم خاصه
بالنسبه للتدفئه مع هذا الطقس البارد
اكثر من 150 الف منزل في الشمال ولايه
نيويورك والولايات
الحدوديه مثل ولايه اوهايو انقطعت عنها
الامدادات الكهربائيه لفترات متقطعه تعود
همم وتنقطع همم يعني هناك ماساه حقيقيه
ليس هناك احصائيات عن ماذا تاثير انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي وانقطاع الغاز بان اقرب
اجهزه في الموجوده في البيوت الامريكيه
خاصه في الشمال الامريكي معتمده اعتمادتها
كامل على الغاز همم
التفاصيل ليست واضحه حتى الان ولكن هناك
توقعات ان يعني اعداد الضحايا سوف تكون
اكبر بكثير همم
طارق طيب يبدو ان
صوت طارق اذن انقطع عنها شكرا جزيلا لك
على العموم اذا ااه طارق الدمشقي كنت معنا
من نيورك هو مشاهدينا نبقى في متابعه هذه
الصور كما ذكرنا يعني هذه عاصفه القرن همم
وكما تبعنا معكم يعني ولايت نيويوركيا
الاكثر تاثرا وعاصفه القرن هذه التي تلقي
بثقالها على نيويورك والنقل الجوي خصوصا
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه اضرابات
بريطانيا تدخل مرحله توسعيه وتفاقم
الخلافات السياسيه في البلاد
الخاصه بهم للقرصنه وفق شركه
اسرائيليه للمعلومات
[موسيقى]
سنه 2022
حول العالم
حركه النزوح التي اعقبت الحرب الاوكرانيه
تتسبب في ارتفاع عدد سكان بعض الدول
المستقبله ابرزها المانيا الذي يتجاوز عدد
سكانها
84 مليون لاول مره في تاريخ الميلاد
اما في المتوسط فان وضع المهاجرين السريين
زاد سوءا حيث ذكر تقرير
في ايطاليا ان التقدير الادنى للاجئين
والمهاجرين الذين ماتوا او فقدوا في البحر
المتوسط من بدايه السنه والى غايه شهر
اكتوبر الماضي
1800 شخص بشكل عام سجلت اعداد اللاجئين
ارتفاع القياسيا حيث تجاوزت لاول مره
عاتبه المئه مليون نجاح حول العالم
[موسيقى]
الاضرابات ولا في تستهدف بشكل اساسي قطاع
النقل في بريطانيا خلافات بين حزب
المحافظين والنقابات العماليه التي تهدد
بتصعيد وتيره للاضطرابات مع بدايه العام
المقبل وتسروا النقابات على الاحتجاج على
اوضاع العمال المعيشيه في ظل ازمه
الاقتصاديه كبيره فيما تحاول حكومه الخروج
من نفق التضخم عبر وضعي حد لرفع الاجور
عبد الحق
وضع بريطانيا المثقل بالاضطرابات على وشك
ان يصبح اكثر ارباكا يخاطر رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني الذي لم يمضي على توليه قياده
الحكومه ثلاثه اشهر بفوضه جديده في البلاد
بدايه العام المقبل مع رفضه مطالبا نقبات
برفع الاجور
فالاضرابات تتضاعف عددا ورقعه انتشارها
تتسع لتشمل قطاعات عده بعضها يشهد اضرابا
لاول مره كادرابات قطاعين الممرضين
والاسعاف في ديسمبر اضافه الى تهديد
نقاباتها بالمزيد من الاضرابات في يناير
ما ينظر بمرحله مطلقه قد يواجهها
البريطانيون في عام 2003
حزب المحافظين الذي يحمله عمال القطاع
العام مسؤوليه الحياه الناس الاخير
عن تحقيق مطالب النقابات لاسباب يقول انها
اقتصاديه يتجه سوناك الى فرد قوانين تضبط
حركه الاضرابات قوانينه تثير الجدل في بلد
يعطي قيمه كبيره لحريه الاحتجاج
هؤلاء العمال
واذا كان ذلك يعني اضراب العمال فليكن
ولكن اذا جعلت ذلك مخالفه للقانون فانا لا
اعتقد ان هذا امر عادل
طرح قوانين للحد من تحركات العمال هذا لا
يبدو ان النقابات التي تملك زخم الاضرابات
تنوي التراجع عن خطوطها قبل تحقيق مطالبها
من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لاين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مواضيع التعاون
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نهايه هذه الساعه كانت هذه ابرز اخبارها
بعد قمع المراه ومقترح بتجميد المساعدات
للضغط على الحركه
تلاحق مئه متظاهر في ايران ومحتاجون
يتحدون قمع النظام بالانتحار والشطرنج
الثلوج تغمر نيورك وتحيله مناطق فيها الى
ساحه حرب شلل في بافلو جثث في السيارات
ومحطات غاز مجمده
[موسيقى]
2012 يسجل رقما قياسيا في اللجوء اكثر من
100 مليون لاجئ حول العالم اغلبهم فارون
من اوكرانيا
شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]